I will make that right choice because
I'm not going to take this situation
lightly I'm not going to let everything
else get to me when it's that big of a
decision for my life she definitely made
a decision Bachelorette Becca is engaged
let's do the dancing an ABC rep
confirmed to et The Bachelor fan
favorite turned Bachelorette says yes to
a proposal by the end of her season we
will have to wait until that season
premieres on May 28 to watch Becca fall
in love with her now fiance but we
couldn't be happier for her after
watching last season's cringe-worthy in
are you proposing then breaking up with
her on national TV only et caught up
with the 28 year old reality star behind
the scenes at her promo photo shoot
ahead of filming her season where she
opened up about the journey ahead my
biggest fear is I mean kind of what
happened like falling for somebody and
ready to spend my life with somebody and
have them not be ready or to be like I
don't know if you're the one for me
[Music]